[Music]
[Applause]
down 6-0 in st louis dodgers came back
to win 7-6 last night the dodgers
manager dave roberts back on the program
good to have you coach how are you
dp what's happening man you doing good
i'm doing okay i just saw where the 2018
red stitch cabernet got 93 points from
wine spectator that's uh dave's wine so
uh congratulations once again on a new
batch
yeah so no it was a good uh it was a
good batch 18 was a great year and your
quick story is we got trace thompson
with us now so
uh clay his brother has his own label
and so i told him we got to go side by
side and uh
compare uh it's a diamond and key it was
nolan aronado ironically and clay
together
uh and myself with redstone so we got to
do a little side by side we might have
to send you a bottle of the diamond and
key
and uh see which one uh wins out
you're down 6-0 last night
what's what's your role when you're down
6-0
i think at that point in time it was
trying to get gallegos into the game and
um
you know it's one of those things where
we're down 6-0 i thought we we waited uh
wayne right out got him out of the game
uh he put up zeros um we got to the pen
who we knew was taxed
and if we could just chip away
and get gallegos in the game at least
there's a chance to salvage a series and
then at that point in time we just chip
away get into the pen who was taxed we
might be able to steal one from them so
that's kind of what we were thinking are
you a rah-rah guy
when you're down 6-0
you know what i'm more of a uh let's
keep
not giving that bats away guy um i
celebrate the victories but in that
moment i'm more trying to keep guys
focused on not just uh
you know
looking looking at the next day and
trying to try to make something good out
of today so that's more my my mindset
when's the last time you purposely got
thrown out of a game
um purposely it was it was this year and
a lot of time it was this year i don't
recall exactly what happened it was more
of
i didn't agree with the zone players
were
you know bitching about it and so i
wanted to
i would rather get tossed than the
player but
i don't need to get tossed to spark our
guys it was more of i'd rather be the
martyr essentially
we're headed towards this
uh strike zone automated strike zone
right
yep i i think so
what's the downside for you
the downside is
most of the hitters complain about it
i i do
like the human element of it behind the
plate
um the downside is a guy like wainwright
with his curveball or a clayton kershaw
which is curveball hitters are going to
be very uh
dissatisfied when they see that
automated strike zone um with guys that
can throw a curveball like that
meaning
it's just going to be the optics of it
the way the catcher catches the ball at
the dirt
when they go north to south 12 to 6
breaking ball that it clips part of the
plate
and it's going to surprise a lot of
players
hitters
but what you're saying is you still like
the human element if if they got a call
wrong
uh and it was the human element or you
got it right with the automated strike
zone
yeah yeah
yeah i i do i i that's kind of my stance
on things and that's that's part of it
learning umpire strike zones and the
pitchers kind of following it the
hitter's adjusting to it and they're not
perfect but they they get a lot more
than they get wrong but why do we allow
a strike zone to vary
um
i think it's just a human essentially
it's a human error
what i will say though dan is
there is a buffer zone right now in
triple a
with the automated strike zone which i
do not think should be there because if
it's automated they don't need the inch
border that essentially
umpires in the big leagues get
for their grading system for the margin
um yeah
plus when you go out to argue with an
automated strike zone it's a little bit
different like
will you be able to argue the same way
when that umpire didn't call it he's
being told what to call
so you can't yeah argue with anybody i
want to see the
uh explain to me
i'm the angel struck out 17 times last
night the astros struck out 15 times and
it doesn't matter what teams i'm talking
about here they combined for 32
strikeouts that's an american league
record for nine innings
help me understand this that
you know
can should you put it in play are you do
do you teach putting it in play or am i
i know i'm old and old school but i
think the crux you're old but you like
money and you understand the value of
the dollar yeah and
the industry does not value
um soft contact or base hits that's just
fact average isn't valued
runs batted in isn't valued
uh
runs are not valued as far as
compensating players so on one hand as a
manager of a ball club i value those
things we value them in our clubhouse
but it's hard to tell a player
when the agent says you might as well
try to go for a pump and hit a homer
because that's what the industry values
i mean it's something that it's so
twisted and
you know we talk about all the time
within the game but when a player talks
to his agent what's going to get you
paid
i remember asking alex rodriguez why he
didn't steal more bases he said once
they start paying me to steal more bases
then i'll do it
and it feels like that's a lost art as
well that
you know you're not stealing bases
that they don't they don't compensate
for stolen bases they pay for play to be
able to post and to take advantage and
potential performance and so again this
is something you and i agree with and
many in the industry do but when you
look at how players are trying to take
care of themselves and families i have
some empathy towards that and i don't
agree with it but i get it
he's dave roberts dodger manager yeah i
just get bummed out because i can watch
highlights and it seems like it's a
great game but if you sit at a game when
everybody's going for the downs there's
no movement whatsoever and that's that's
been my biggest knock is at least have
movement you know take the extra bass
move a runner over but you know
uh i'm i'm shouting and nobody nobody's
going to be listening about listening to
this anytime soon
yeah and the thing is though is that
that's the thing is that to ultimately
um i think our club
in the last few weeks has done a much
better job of playing team baseball
situationally moving guys over taking
taking the extra bay stealing bases
taking walks and
to 111 games in october
you've got to be able to do that because
the pitching gets considerably better
the scouting gets better you got to be
able to move the ball forward
take walks
when pitchers expand so um
that's something that we're very mindful
of
because our goal is to win a world
series
when you're looking at pitching now
in high school or college
um
are you tell me how you scout now with a
picture as opposed to what it was like
when you were actually playing and what
we expected from a starting pitcher has
anything has it changed that
dramatically
i think
i don't think that's changed as much um
you're still looking at body
projectibility you're looking at
arm strength
you're looking at mechanics to
potentially look at long-term health
i think the guys
back when i came up there were guys
drafted
with pitch ability
and command where that for me i just
don't think is prioritized as much as
just pure arm strength
yeah because i wonder
if clayton kershaw was coming out now or
justin verlander
would they be viewing adam wainwright
yeah but they they would they be viewed
differently that i don't need a
workhorse
or
we're not as reliant on these workhorses
going seven eight nine innings anymore
i think so yeah i do um you know those
guys you know adam wainwright started
the sixth inning with 105 pitches and um
you know he's a workhorse and as you
said verlander kershaw
and that when they came into the game
there were obviously a lot more complete
games um
you know people that
were mentors for them you know taught
them a certain way and the industry i
think is kind of downshifted as far as
expecting length of the starter
um
and the bullpen management
um you know multi-inning guy has been
more of a commodity
but i do think that baseball is
certainly trying to
get back to the starter going deeper in
the game because yeah when you're
looking at probables and you see kershaw
verlander
that's exciting and that's something
that one that gets baseball fans tuned
in
all right we're 10 minutes in uh how
would you
sum up the freddie freeman weekend in
atlanta
um
overwhelming
exhausting
very fun
what role did you play
i played the uh
the intermediate
um
uh friend
coach
uh media liaison
um
kind of a motivator to the team to keep
us focused on trying to beat the atlanta
braves
how surprised were you
about the emotion that hit him
and uh sort of the fallout
i wasn't i wasn't um that's something
that we had talked about uh months
leading up to it so that was just a
culmination and uh i thought the fans
there in atlanta handle it fantastic uh
the organization did a fantastic job and
for freddie to finally get closure um he
was having a heck of a year for us
already dan
but to have that closure uh what he's
done in the last month has been just you
know from that point on has been
remarkable
was anybody bothered by it did you have
to have discussions in the locker room
there wasn't and i think honestly it's
like there was a little something made
of clayton's yeah tongue-in-cheek
comment but it's like that's something
that if clayton's gonna say something
it's gonna get blown out of proportion
and it wasn't at all i mean
if there's any person that could realize
understand being with an organization
for your entire career through the minor
leagues and have to go back
it's clayton so um no not at all
do you ever cry going back to a ballpark
i have not um i did get i do get
received well going back to boston and
and uh to fenway but i i didn't shed a
tear but you know i actually i i i can
appreciate a person who can show us
emotions they'll go out there and throw
a couple knocks in a game
okay but if you go back to atlanta
during the postseason you have to have a
conversation with freddie to say all
right there's no more tears all right
one and done you got your tears now
you're a dodger okay let's go get him
yeah yeah no doubt no doubt um i i think
the tears of all he's all cried out and
i think that when he gets back there
won't be cheers for him anyway there's
gonna be
uh if it's the nlcs or something like
that he's gonna be received with some
booze i'm sure uh respectful booze well
also
he's playing well that was the thing if
if that happened and he wasn't playing
well
then i think the fallout might have been
different like dude you know you gotta
you're in a different zip code a
different uniform like you've got to
start raking here but he has been
hitting as advertised
he he's done everything is advertised on
the field off the field he's absolutely
done it how many people hit you up for
uh all-star game tickets
uh yeah
quite a few but uh you know my
complimentary tickets are all tapped out
so uh you're paying uh market value
uh going forward so yeah i'm tapped out
on the complimentary home run derby and
tickets so uh
yeah but it's a good number it's a big
number but have you had a man would you
have a manager who might
ask you to
limit the amount of pitches that you
know one you know or limit the time that
somebody's in there a starter
is that something that happens oh it
happened oh yeah that's that's that's
the thing um you know i had the fortune
of managing two all-star games and um
yeah they uh they call to try to
either not pitch your pit their pitcher
or at least go one inning so it's funny
is that you get calls from major league
baseball saying oh so-and-so go two so
and so can go two and then you get the
call a couple days prior after you made
the uh the list of how you're going to
use these guys and says
yeah my guy can only go one or can you
keep him out of the game and so there's
a lot of that going on great to talk to
you again good catching up uh safe
travels thanks for joining us
all right gp take care we'll talk soon
that's dave roberts
he comes on he never
asked me to talk about his uh red stitch
cabernet so uh got 93 points from wine
spectator and uh he's had a he's had a
couple of really good years there